Now in this section, we're going to talk about camera control systems and then create a virtual
live link subject so that we can do it ourselves if you don't have one of these camera control
systems. Camera control systems can stream lens data directly into Unreal Engine using any one
of the optional peripheral devices that you can pick up from vendors such as Preston's hand
view it. Now to calculate lens distortion, the lens file asset needs to know both the focal length
and focus distance of the lens that's being used. There are several available hardware options
that are capable of streaming Fizz data from production cameras to Unreal Engine through a
live link plugin. The Master Lock It, Preston MDR and the DCS plugin are all viable options,
but most vendors should have an optional plugin that you can download from their website and
use in conjunction with Unreal Engine. Now some hardware connects to smart lenses made by Zeiss
and Cook. Other devices connect directly to focus systems such as the Preston and these are
commonly used by first ASCs for adjusting or pulling focus and controlling the aperture or
iris of the camera. Now the DCS lens data translator can convert smart lens data in
addition to streaming lens data from different focus systems. Additionally, RE also has a
hand focus system and the RE-CAM metadata plugin for streaming that Fizz data. Note this is
required using the pre-built 5.0 plugin and it is up to RE to determine when this plugin will be
updated for 5.1. Additional notes here that you want to be aware of is that distortion of a real
lens needs to be emulated by the CG lens to have the same distortion characteristics when adding
AR or CG extensions that are not seen in camera view, but are added as a composite layer. These
distortion parameters will change as the focus is changed during a tape and by streaming the Fizz
data, the camera in the Unreal Engine can be updated in real time by the lens file and apply
these values to the CG composite elements. If you don't have this, your post team is likely to throw
away everything that you've shot and redo this in post. So if we want to pull our camera control
systems for calibration and we want to do this on our own, we're going to need a live link virtual
subject. So let's jump over to the Unreal Engine. Now if you don't have access to per-refrials for
streaming, a virtual live link subject blueprint can be used to manually input focus, aperture,
and focal length values with the following steps. To begin, we're going to move over to our calibration
folder and we are going to create a folder for lens files. Let's go new folder, lens files,
and inside that folder, we are going to create a new blueprint. So let's go ahead and right click
here and go to live link because we need a virtual subject. So we're going to create a blueprint
virtual subject. So again, right click, move up to our live link and go to blueprint virtual subject.
Now the role that we're going to choose for this is going to be our live link camera role. So we're
going to choose this from our drop-down menu and go ahead and click OK. Now this is going to give us
our blueprint, which we are going to rename BP for blueprint, live link virtual subject or LLVS
and we're going to give this the black magic Zeiss underscore 25 for our lens name. We want to do
that so that we know what subject this is actually controlling with our lens camera combination.
Once that's done, we can go ahead and double click on this to open it up so that we can start building
our blueprint. Now as we get started in here, you are going to want to create a few variables.
So we're going to move up to the upper left hand corner here and you're going to see this option
called variables and I'm going to start with hitting this plus button. My first variable,
I'm going to change this type from Boolean to float and I'm going to rename this variable
the focus. So this is the F in our fizz for focus. Now I want to make sure that this is
instance editable. So I'm just going to go ahead and click on this little eyeball and that makes
it instance editable. Now I'm going to need a few more versions of this. So let's go ahead and
duplicate this by hitting control D and let's rename this one to iris and do control D one more
time and let's call this one zoom. So now we have focus iris and zoom or as we like to call them for
short fizz. Now we need to go into our event graph and from here we need to create some event
options. So we're going to start out here with our event on initialize. Let's move this up to the
corner so we can kind of focus on it. I'm going to drag out from my executable and I'm going to
create a new node and this one I'm going to type in update virtual subject and I want to select
the subject from my static data. So I'm going to choose update virtual subject static data.
Now with my static data I do want to hover over my static data pin and I want to right click on this
and split my structure pin. Splitting my structure pin is going to give me a number of options to
work with and I want to make sure that these options that I want to work with are enabled.
So the first one I want to enable here is the static data is focal length supported. Next I want
to make sure that my static data is aperture supported and finally let's make sure that my
static data is focus distance supported. Now I have my virtual subject ready to go and I need to
create a few more options here. So I'm going to do the same thing over on my event on update
and in my event on update I'm going to drag this out and I'm going to go ahead and search again
for update virtual subject but I'm going to look this time for my frame data. So in this version
I'm going to on my update choose my frame data. Now just like before I'm going to move this over
and I'm going to hover over my frame data and I'm going to right click on this I'm going to split
this structure pin. Now I've split my structure pin and I can see that I've got a couple options
here frame data focal length frame data aperture and frame data focus distance. Now I'm going to
start with my focus distance and what I'm going to do here is I'm just going to drag for my focus
distance and I'm going to look for a variable and that variable is going to end up being my focus.
So I'm going to get my focus my focus is the variable that I created so let's go ahead and
grab that. Now I can also drag one of these in so let's drag in my iris and let's get my iris
and you can see it's the same kind of node I'm going to connect that to my data aperture.
Now again I can always drag this off and I can always search so I'm looking for my zoom and I
can just get my zoom and now I have my variables controlling my focal length. So each of these
variables actually grab all of my focus distance my aperture and my focal length. Once this is done
and assembled all I really need to do right now is go ahead and hit compile and then save and that's
pretty much it for our virtual live link subject creation. Now we need to make sure that this
subject is accessible so I'm going to go ahead and close my blueprint and you can see I've got my
virtual subject in here and I'm going to move over to the right side of my screen to my live link
section. If you don't have your live link tab you just go under window you can move on down to
virtual production and open up this live link tab that'll give you this option in here and now I
need to create and add a virtual subject to my source. So inside my live link tab I'm going to go
ahead and hit this source button and I'm going to go add virtual subject. I'm going to go ahead and
click that button. Now I'm going to give myself a virtual subject name and so I want to make sure
that I rename this subject so I'm going to call this live link virtual subject black magic Zeiss
25 and that's going to give me my live link virtual subject and then I'm going to choose the
virtual subject that we just created so I'm going to choose the blueprint that we created here.
That's going to allow me to add the subject name telling me what this is that I'm using
and add that to my source here. Now you can see I've got my black magic subject name in here
and that's going to give me the option to control my focus iris and zoom in my live link virtual
camera. Now in order to make this work you'll see over here I've got my NBC camera. I'm going to move
up to my outliner and select my camera. With my camera selected I need to add in a new option so
let's look at our details panel. Now in my details panel I should have a tracked object in here and
I don't have my tracking setup just yet but we're going to need that in order to track our camera
for our option. What I'm going to do is I'm going to need to first create my live link fizz data in
order to control that so hit this add button and in my add button I'm going to type in live link
and you can see I've got two options live link skeletal animation and live link controller so
I'm going to use controller and this is a live link component controller so I'm going to call this
ll underscore cc for live link component controller black magic underscore zice and this is my fizz
data so I'm just going to type fizz on the end of this. I'm going to hit enter and I'm going to choose
my subject representation. For this you can see I've got my black magic zice 25 I'm going to choose
my camera roll and this is actually going to control my camera roll so now my fizz data is
going to be controlled from my camera and that's going to actually control and allow me to make
those changes so that any of my focus iris and zoom are going to be set in here. Now if you have
forgotten how to do a tracked object in here you just want to make sure that your source is active
and you want to load in a source for your opti track and then connect that source and make sure
that's set for your preset. That's it for creating your virtual live link subject. Next we're going
to talk about one more little tool before we do our lens calibration.